>> Kenny: McDAVID WITH KANE ANT
.
>> Keith: HE WAS AWESOME LAST
NIGHT AN BY McDAVID AND NOW
ORLOV WITH THEN EVANDER KANE.
GOOD, QUICK HOT.
REDIRECT BY KANE.
SECOND GOAL IN THREE GAMES WITH
EDEDMcDAVID, SPECTACULAR MOVE BD
THE NET AND E OILER'S POWER
PLAY CONNECTS HERE FOR THE THIRD
GOAL OF THE GAME.
YOU CAN SEE ON
BOUCHARD, UNABLE TO CLEAR.
PUCK PUCK UP RIGHT
THERE.
TRY TO GET BACK TO ANDD ONE, Mc
HAS  BROKEN UPM WILSON.
CHIPS THE PUCK.
AND NOW KUZNETSOV WILL CIRCLIN
PERIOD NUMBER LEAGUE.
>> Kenny: WHAT WAS IT LIKE TO E
WOUND WIND UP WITH THE CAPITALS,
BUT NOT THAT WAY BOARDS.
EVANDE DANIEL
A
GOAL HERE FROM
PLAY THE PUCK FOR WASHINGTON
PLAYERS.
RIOD.
McLEOD INTO THE CORNER.
PUCK ACROSS THE CREASE.
FELL TO HI DARNELL NURSE.
QUICK SHOT.
HE DOES EXTEND HIS LEGF
THERE AND TWICE I BELIEV
IT WAS IN THE AREAIN ON HAGELIN.
THREE PENALTY.
NEAR COMING UP.
BARRIE HAD TROUBR CARLSON
AND NOW THE OILERS COME OUT., G
HUSTLE UP THE ICE.
DOES NOT END UP ON A NUGENT-HOP.
TO THE EMPTY NET, HE SCORES.HER.
I THOUGHT COPLEY WAS A A